everybody's heard the stories of musadir
we know the stories about you know
Muhammad a few people know about
razakhan his father how he also was in
Exile and then Khomeini comes in after
being in Exile twice Boom the next thing
you know Shah leaves and Iran changes
but there were a lot of people that were
for the Shah Fallen there were a lot of
people that said that Shaw's a bad
person you know you got savak you did
this we should have had mosadir we
should have had this person you know
some say musada was a CIA plant some say
the shaw was the puppet of the West you
hear all of these things right and even
some of the kids whatever the kids
believe in is whatever their parents
told them for the most part you know if
you're Christian it's probably because
your parents are Christians if you're
Muslim you're Muslim if you're you know
an LDS sometimes you're an LDS about 80
percent of the time we follow our uh uh
our parents uh religion and beliefs that
they have except if there's a broken
family then typically you don't want to
follow one of them because one of them
left and you're kind of like screwed I
don't want to follow your whatever it
may be right there's like an animosity
towards a parent
uh how much of what you know we hear uh
on the monarchy side the criticism of
God how much of that criticism was real
how much of that criticism in your
opinion obviously you know there's only
so much context we have on what we're
talking about what is the difference
between a criticism that got under
Shah's regime versus the criticism it
got under the theocracy we've had the
last 43 years I'll go to you first well
I wasn't alive then but from what I know
um you know so I feel like the
experiences here are going to be able to
speak to it better but from of course
what I've researched and I've been to
Iran many times and you know family and
all that kind of stuff speaking to my
family
um the criticism of the Shah was valid
obviously in the sense that it created
enough dis descent in his own country
that people thought they wanted this
revolution
um they didn't want what came some of
them did but after hominy came in
um everyone was like wait what this is
not what you promised us because as they
can attest to there was how many would
send in cassette tapes from his Exile in
France and it was these sermons and he
was he was saying yeah yeah he was
saying at the original going viral it
was saying about how he was gonna you
know women were gonna be equal and
everything was going to be great and
we're going to go back to this type of a
country where it's a little bit more
modest we're gonna get the West Out and
because people were fed up with a lot of
people were fed up with the shot not
everybody
um they were for this and then um your
sister brought up a good point the it's
really interesting that in 1979 when
komini came and was and said actually
hijab is going to be mandatory the women
were like whoa that's not what you
promised us so the same women that were
protesting now somebody I heard said the
scholar academ the same women that
protested in 1979 against the hijab
their granddaughters now are avenging
them which is really it's a really
interesting parallel because they were
literally getting beat up in the streets
as well and they all said afterward we
didn't get what we thought we were gonna
get there's actually a great documentary
that if you're listening owners want if
they want to get more familiar with Iran
it came out on HBO a few days ago or
last week it's called hostages four four
part mini documentary series and it
shows you how we got into the hostage
crisis with the Shah leaving and Carter
and Khomeini and aftermath and it's
really really great for people who don't
know that much about Iran's history
fantastic yeah sure what would you say
you know again criticism pre-sha when
Shah was there you know the uh 2500 year
anniversary he spent way too much money
can you pull up uh put to Iran 2500 year
anniversary put this big celebration it
was a big deal and it created so much
criticism amongst people saying why
would you spend this much money go
actually to the pictures so people can
see what it was like uh you go to the
pictures and show actually what it was
like uh man if you can show a real good
one okay yeah right there a lot of
people participated in that a lot of
people around the country that's right
it was a big deal
celebrities political leaders you know
so some people saw that and they said
wow look how strong Iran's becoming but
some people saw that in Iran and people
like Khomeini they said look how rich
the Shah has become and he has all the
money and you're poor and he's taken all
the money what if we can nationalize the
oil what if we can do this what if we
can do that what if we can have free
rights what if we cannot free this and
people actually started falling for this
so morteza from your perspective you're
living there at that time the criticism
that the Shah got that led to 99 million
people revolting against him
versus reality compared to what happened
under Khomeini give us the difference
between the two
as a matter of fact practitioner about
this uh
that Year my brother took me to uh
seventh Air Force Base in Shiraz and I
lived there I saw that demonstration you
were there I was next to the street we
were clapping for the whole thing you
have no idea what kind of honor it had
between all these presidents and Kings
invited there to see our Rich culture we
bring it up to the wall that look who we
are we deserve where we are and we
deserve where we want to go
I sort of agree with the uh nozzanine
when she said if the door was a little
bit open Shaw would let people know all
those things that they were pretending
that they want to bring it
they wouldn't fall for it they wouldn't
fall for it I was working from the ninth
grade 10th grade yeah in a bookstore
right in front of the Tehran University
it was a GB bookstore that was belongs
to enter Charlotte de Francine and I was
a archivist I was taking the inventory
in and out and I was behind the black
glass window
and I would see like how students come
in and looking at this side and that
side and passing for example
to each other and they were scared like
if someone see them let them see that
there is nothing in there it's a kid's
book why are you making this guy so big
that people make it that oh so what's
this song it wasn't a big deal we made
it savak wasn't a big deal it wasn't a
bit what what soak did sovak is just to
put in context book savak was Iran's CIA
at that time that was trained by the CIA
by the way any country have a security
system that's right of course which
country has it right sure for the saving
this uh country right but point is they
were doing stupid things they were doing
like you'd think that it wasn't a big
deal at all what I say if cha would let
Jose almier home
get to open the door for everyone nobody
would watch this regime nobody everybody
knows like what's the origin what's the
inside the regime they closed it closed
that people are like oh it must be a
magic in there then let's go vote yeah
we saw him in the moon all of this
you're saying if he would have uh
allowed people the freedom to learn and
have other other ideologies and thoughts
exactly right that he would yeah so he
shouldn't have been afraid of two-day
party like a Communist party that was
coming in or any of those guys and more
important than that Patrick leadership
comes with a responsibility sure if
you're a leader sometimes you have to
say something that maybe 90 don't like
it but six months from now they adore
you for saying it and standing on your
position sure right
when
whole thing was the starting
my expectation from show was as a leader
of the country that we loved what he did
for the country we we love what his
father did for the country put his foot
down and does it say let me step out of
the country see what they're gonna do
and we paid for it 43 years
to become a most dry country most
poorest country I'm saying he shouldn't
have left no he should have left he
should okay okay so let's process that
let's actually go there if he doesn't
leave what happens you think the people
weren't going to go into the palace and
go in there and get them you don't think
that was good they put in the story for
the cinematics they did they couldn't
story for the maid you know if they shot
him that they did because they would
find out that what happened it wasn't a
17 000 death it was 173.
they made these stories big and big and
big and because he was not defending he
was just acting very gentle man very
like a
like a classy but doesn't but doesn't
that contradict your argument to say
that if you would have let the two-day
party just come in and present their
arguments you know on one end you're
saying he should have let them on the
other end you're saying he was he wasn't
paranoid enough so if he's too paranoid
Hey Hey listen these two gay guys let's
arrest him put him in the jail on the
other side no no he wasn't too uh you
know paranoid enough how many had more
power than it really did he should have
really controlled it more so it's like a
it's almost like a that's a game a
leadership playing game leadership
playing game when pool when push yeah I
don't know about that one that's that's
going to be a tough one for him to play
thoughts and I was gonna say don't
forget also the Americans role behind
the scenes of all this too they were
they were afraid of the spread of any
type of Communism or anything like that
so they had a vested interest in
playing the parts in the leadership when
you say American leaders who are you
referencing anyone is specific no the
administration when Jimmy Carter towards
the end yeah got it so got it well I
mean you know we're in the US right now
because of Jimmy Carter there's no Jimmy
Carter we'll probably be still in Iran
right now we're getting pulled from
every side yeah our patient golf is
belongs to 90 right it belongs to China
gas and gold is Russia obviously West
and East are pulling Iran apart and it's
not in their benefit that right not
supporting people
but also Shaw was dealing with his own
Shah was dealing with his own health
also
right his health was deteriorating
towards the end so it was kind of like
the timing of all of it come together so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]